in writing for the green light you have
chapter 4 and that's entitled how I
learned to stop worrying and write for
television yes I love that title so can
you talk about some of the highlights of
that chapter yeah when I was sort of
newer to the industry there was always
sort of two schools of thought you
either wrote for television or he wrote
from movies the movie side is kind of
cut and dry there's the three-act
structure etc whereas televisions kind
of all over the map and what I was
always taught when I was younger was you
have to write a spec script of a major
TV series that you can kind of showcase
your talent and showcase you know how to
you know grasp how television works etc
etc but in this chapter I kind of
exposed television as being very
different than movies in in the movie
side I'm very adamant never write drama
never write comedy when you're starting
out if you have great ideas for drama
and comedy and you want to write
features excellent just back-pocket them
for a while and get the contacts first
televisions the complete opposite in
television you should really focus on
writing only drama or only comedy and
doing both extremely extremely well and
if you're gonna be doing drama you want
to focus on our long dramas if you want
to do comedy you want to focus on
half-hour comedies and that's just
something that's a polar opposite of how
you're gonna break into the film side of
things television is kind of breaking
some of the things I talked about in the
movie side the other thing with TV is
it's open-ended movies have a beginning
a middle Internet and there is a
conclusion and there's something we pull
from it after we experience it TV needs
to be not a story arc it needs to be a
platform a strong platform built with
interesting characters who are
consistently able to be reintroduced to
each other with new beginning middle end
episodes and then reput together and
reput together time and time and time
again when best shows on TV is law and
order it does this in a fantastic way
I believe it
almost a thousand episodes across all
the different you know types of the show
the styles of the show but what it is is
it doesn't matter where you begin that
show you can start that show any season
any episode and you are not missing a
thing there are great character
development to take place with the
characters if you watch all the episodes
but you're not you do not have to watch
it in a chronological order if you've
missed the first five episodes you you
don't have to go catch up you know if
some if if you start in the middle of an
episode you can actually catch up with
where things are going because each
thing is a self-contained you know short
form movie that can just replicate and
replicate and replicate what star Trak
is it's a great platform for a
consistent endless output of content and
television isn't just that we're
thinking scripted here most television
content is non-scripted factual content
or you know late-night talk shows
you know lifestyle programs that have
narration remember you know these
programs need writers to they have to be
organized and orchestrated and
documentaries have to be you know pieced
together
magazine shows like news programs have
to be written so for writers who want to
get a beginning start in the business
television sometimes offers really
interesting out-of-the-box ways to get
your feet wet you can go to any of the
shows that film here the late-night talk
shows and and become a joke writer
they'll pay you you know you submit your
jokes every single day and then you know
the pay for the ones they use and the
comedians on the shows don't write the
monologue every night it's a team of
writers that's a great way to be on set
and to become a staff writer you know
getting your work out there and exposed
and and and you know working in talk
shows or any other kind of factual place
gets you into the business of working
with these people and it's a great
stepping stone to begin working in the
scripted world as to in fact that's how
I Met Your Mother the team behind that
that's where they came from was writing
gags and jokes for late-night talk shows
and they they got access to the studio
and built their way up from there
on the personal side meanwhile of course
they're writing like hell at night and
working and building up their portfolio
of work so writing well though you said
I mean I know that's very subjective and
and but but some things are going to
take and some things aren't what you're
asking is what constitutes good writing
and if you write well if you were
writing scripts or stories or treatments
that are just great ideas that's all you
have to do as a writer and that's not
the case you have to get those not just
- it's not just getting those to the
right people it's not a misleading them
now eventually if I keep throwing
spaghetti at the wall it'll stick it's
structured and strategized to be a
writer you have to think about what gets
produced as I said movies cost a lot of
money TV shows cost even more money in a
sense to produce and it costs a lot of
money to market to people so there's an
audience ready to watch it on the other
side so if you are writing stuff that's
kind of catered to that or that's when
when TV shows and movies need a writer
if you're writing to be seen as that
writer who can deliver it you're not
throwing spaghetti against the wall
you're going in with a strategy with a
game plan with and with an objective and
a plan it's it's if you just write
aimlessly you're not there's always
exceptions of course and outliers but
your chances of being able to just like
write something great and have it get
picked up and turn into a studio movie
like it's just not going to happen but
you can strategically set up your career
in a way where you are writing stuff
that the industry needs and you will see
people coming to you and working with
you or taking your calls or asking to
read your stuff
you